in the ACC share the regular-season
title with Virginia and it's Colby White
gets up the first shot and the first
bucket of the game from the freshman
yeah and this is the play the North
Carolina loved self were more
importantly his teammates in the spot
that they need
Andrea rest out of it chocolate for the
first time for the gals and white
berries
another three third year now in the
second year at North Carolina great play
for all that time by coach Roy Williams
the fastest pace in the country and they
grow fast and white scores and he is
fine and he's right at the head of the
attack it is something special
it's a difference between playing fast
and playing with pace he is one of the
special guard Crawford and he lost the
handle right into the hands of Brooks
white in transition white goes and
that's a block and one for Kobe white
and another opportunity the three-point
possession for the heels
right the middle of that saw batiste
evil pasceri Katyn all-time steals
record and white hits at three-putt
title that time but Kobe white shooting
it from curry range on did Robinson on
the floor his first minutes Williams
gives it up right open again two three
knocks another one down he's not saying
offensive foul that execution right
there and you can be one of the best
defensive teams he can get his own look
the seer little bit was deflected but we
might step back top 300 Kobe Dwight
gotta cook it early Kobe white a little
pittypat recognized sees the three-point
line steps to his right bang finished
with a 17 point victory only widen
another three on the way at another
three rounds oh come on I snapped a 30
no run now bay hits the three white sand
fancy dribbling fancy man lightning-fast
all the way down the floor after the
make Kobe white Wow
South and the time on the clock so they
are averaging to their 17th one seed
Washington a 17 NCAA Tournament
appearances as Kobe's white
senior connect doing the work on the
offensive plants just and look at this
wide hyperspeed and gotten away with the
step good work they're up front pull-ups
one count a long two pointer for Kobe
white but Bruce Pearl really has got a
good understanding of how the rise the
hot shooter white gets to the rim and a
chance at a three-point play early
looking for an answer white driving it
to the basket gets the reach-in foul
that it's 76-59 over North Carolina it's
just not getting into a flow whitelist
and slam and a chance at three Oh Jim
turned the corner and if you just for a
second arm back there waiting for him
it's way too late good call from the
officials